What are they thinking?
Welcome to Unfiltered. I'm S.E. Cupp.
If you've been following the 2024
presidential primaries,
you know that
every week
seemingly brings a new hopeful
into the races.
Over on the left, President Joe Biden
as challengers
in anti-vax crusader Robert F Kennedy Jr.
Spiritual leader Marianne Williamson
and most recently scholar
activist Cornel West
who is running
on the People's Party ticket.
On the right, it's getting very crowded.
Former President Donald Trump,
former Vice President Mike Pence.
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis.
Former New Jersey
Governor Chris Christie.
Former South
Carolina Governor Nikki Haley.
And U.S.
Senator Tim
Scott of South Carolina
are all announced candidates
on the Republican ticket.
Those are some pretty familiar names.
But have you heard
of these GOP contenders?
Doug Burgum,
he's the governor of North Dakota
and he's running for president,
apparently Asa Hutchinson,
he's the former governor of Arkansas.
And he's also running.
Steve Laffey, he's the former
mayor of Cranston, Rhode Island.
Population
80 2000 hometown of my husband.
What about Michigan businessman
Perry Johnson,
former Montana secretary of State?
Corey Stapleton
or tax consultant John Anthony Castro?
Yes.
All of these people
and more are running for president.
In 20, 24.
That's over a dozen declared
Republican candidates
so far,
with a few others
mulling additional bids.
It's starting to feel eerily
similar to 2016
when 17 people
voted for president on the right.
We all know how that went.
Trump used
the saturation to his advantage
and won the nomination
with just a plurality,
not a majority of the vote
this year with many early primary states
winner takes all.
Trump could eke out
narrow wins
and still collect all their delegates.
That means that every time
someone else gets in the race,
Trump's chances
of clinching the nomination again
get better and better.
That math is explicitly why Republicans
like former Maryland Governor Larry Hogan
and current
New Hampshire Governor Chris
Sununu decided not to run.
They don't want to help Trump
Presumably, some of these
candidates believe they can beat Trump,
who's polling at 53% among
Republican registered voters.
According to a May CNN poll,
DeSantis is polling
closest to Trump at 26%.
Pence and Haley are behind him at 6%.
Scott and Christie are polling at 2%,
Hutchinson in Burgum at 1%.
Now, look, it's
a long 18 months until November 2024
and a lot can happen.
But you have to wonder
what are some of these folks thinking?
Are these campaigns
merely vanity projects,
book sales boosters,
fundraising missions,
a chance
to see the country on donors dimes?
With the stakes so high this year
and Trump poised to claw his way back
into the White House, where he spent
four years
trying to systematically
dismantle democracy.
Is this really the time to say why not?
And hope for a miracle?
I get it.
Everyone thinks
they can save the country
but there are practical matters here.
Name recognition,
money,
resources, and most importantly, math.
Lamentably running for president
in America
is not an equal opportunity endeavor
for anyone of age.
And citizenship can technically run,
but very few are ever actually
in positions to win
the party's
governing bodies
ensure that that's the case.
So this feels a little self-serving.
And isn't that the exact quality?
We don't want in a president again?
That's it for me. See you next week.